new data is showing the world's largest
tropical rainforest is shrinking
fast scientists have for years been
warning that the amazon is disappearing
at an alarming rate
especially in brazil it's the last
refuge for many endangered wildlife
and home to millions of species some of
them still
unidentified and now research shows that
the deforestation of the brazilian
amazon
rose for the fourth consecutive month in
june hitting a record high
in the first six months of this year
alone it went up by
17 more than 3
500 square kilometers of amazon have
been cleared already
that's almost three times the size of
the city of rio de janeiro
many blame the government
this continues to happen because of the
government's environmental policy
encouraged by the national congress at
april's climate change summit hosted by
us president joe biden brazil's
president jaya bolsonaro pledged to
eliminate the illegal logging of the
amazon in the next few years
i'm determined that we will achieve our
climate neutrality by 2050
10 years ahead of our previous target
but satellite imagery suggests otherwise
and environmentalists say since
bolsonaro took office in 2019
the destruction has been happening at a
rapid rate
as institutions and legislations to
protect the rainforest and its
indigenous people
are increasingly marginalized
earlier this month and after weeks of
protests brazil's supreme court
postponed a ruling backed by the farming
sector
that would limit recognition of
indigenous lands
there's an attempt to pass laws in the
national congress with bowl 490
that takes away the territorial rights
of indigenous people
it's a signal to loggers and illegal
farmers on the rainforest grounds
that are willing to commit crimes from
the invasion of indigenous territories
deforestation and setting fires
scientists say the protection of the
amazon is vital to curbing climate
change
because of the vast amount of greenhouse
gases that the forest absorbs
june however had the biggest number of
forest fires since 2007
and that's only a fraction of those seen
annually during the peak of drought
season in august and september
and now there are fears the worst is yet
to come
al jazeera